[crying]
Narrator: This crying
woman isn't crying at all.
Elaine Hall: And a baby'll start to cry.
Narrator: She's what's
known as a baby wrangler,
someone whose job it is
to get the best performances
out of the youngest actors.
This is just one of the
many surprising positions
you will find on a movie or TV set.
Cameraman: Whoa!
Narrator: There are
people who train insects,
style food,
and even design clothes
for animated films.
These jobs are essential
to making movies work.
Let's take a look behind the scenes
at eight jobs in movies you
may not have known existed.
It's not only real actors
who need costume designers,
but animated characters as well.
At Pixar, there are people
who are specifically
hired to animate clothing,
like tailoring and simulation
artist Kris Campbell.
They have to design and model clothes
and then make sure they fit
on the animated characters.
This process involves computer simulations
to make sure the fabric moves correctly.
In "Coco," for example,
these simulations helped
them prevent clothes
from getting stuck in the
skeleton characters' bones.
Campbell's work throughout the years
prepared him for "Onward."
However, he wasn't just
animating clothes this time.
In this film, the item of
clothing was a character.
Acting out how the animated
characters move in real life
can provide reference.
When the animators in
"Onward" needed to figure out
how a floating pair of pants would behave,
they put someone in a green
suit and a pair of khaki pants
and observed what it would look like
to see somebody walking around
who was missing the
top half of their body.
While a clothing animator
focuses on clothing,
they still have a great understanding
of how every aspect of animation works.
Dad's upper half in "Onward"
had no muscle underneath,
making simulations much more challenging.
So Campbell relied on a simulation created
for characters with volume,
which was originally used
for the squishy movements
of Hank the octopus in "Finding Dory."
And they need to add
small details to clothes
that you would normally expect to see,
like little threads hanging off a sweater.
A vital but unexpected
part of the job: shading.
Lighting can help textures
look more realistic,
which can sell the whole look.
This is the reason why Dad's vest
looks naturally puffy instead of plastic.
Productions try to use real
food whenever they can,
and when they do,
a food stylist comes in to handle it all.
It's a lot more than just altering dishes
to fit an actor's dietary restrictions,
though that is certainly part of the job.
Food stylist Zoe Hegedus
had to solve a number
of different problems
on the set of "Midsommar."
The film was mostly shot
outdoors in the heat,
so she had to make sure the food
both looked and stayed fresh.
Sometimes, this was as easy
as spraying a potato with cooking spray
to make it look like it
just came out of the oven.
Other dishes needed to be altered
entirely to beat the heat.
For example, those meat
pies you see on screen
aren't filled with real meat,
which would spoil quickly.
Instead, Hegedus cooked
oatmeal and colored it brown,
giving it the look and
texture of chopped meat.
She also had to plate a lot
of eggs for the Sun's Eye dish
that was prominently featured
during one of the film's many feasts.
First, she tried making some real eggs,
but the yolks kept exploding,
meaning she and her team
had to swap the dishes
out every 15 minutes.
Plus, workdays could last 10 to 12 hours,
so there was a risk of them drying out.
Instead, she decided to make this mixture
out of orange and mango juice
and shaped it to look
exactly like real yolks.
And what does a food stylist do
when they have to find an item
that's not even available
where they're filming?
For one pivotal moment,
they needed to have a fresh herring,
which is abundant in Sweden
but not so much in Hungary,
where the movie was shot.
The fish had to be real
in order to get this horrified
reaction from Florence Pugh.
Eventually, she had to
get 20 pieces of herring
shipped in from France,
meaning they had only 20
tries to get it right.
Luckily, they nailed it
after seven or eight tries.
Some foods are just too difficult
to use the real thing on set.
For example, real ice cream
would melt too quickly.
Or maybe you need a lot of food
to sit in the background of a shot.
In these instances, a
fake-food artist is essential.
This scene in "Glee" was set in a diner
and called for lots of ice cream sundaes,
milkshakes, and banana splits
on the tables and counters.
Fake versions were needed
so they would appear fresh
and new the entire time.
Fake-food artist Brenda Chapman
made a variety of these desserts,
which were set at various
stages of being eaten.
When someone like Lisa Friedman
needs to make fake food,
she'll first get a real version
of the food she needs to recreate.
Then she makes a mold of that item.
She pours a mixture of rubber and foam
into that same mold to create the shape,
but it isn't until the
item is hand-painted
that it starts to look
like the real thing.
Aside from being a great painter,
being a fake-food artist
means getting creative with the materials.
To make granola and ground beef,
Friedman took corkboard and crushed it,
giving her just the right texture.
Sometimes, a character will
need different-looking eyes
than the performer portraying them,
such as Hugh Jackman's bloodshot
eyes in "Les Misérables."
In these cases,
they'll go somewhere like
Eyeworks for Film in London.
Putting contacts on can
completely change the color
of an actor's eyes.
It can also make them look older
or even like another species.
First, the designer will
get a brief description
of the character,
then they'll research what
the look should look like,
develop concept art,
and then finally check the actor's eyes
to fit the contacts for them.
In order for the contacts
to feel normal and natural to wear,
director of Eyeworks
for Film Sinead Sweeney
says the contacts they design
have to sit directly on top of the cornea.
They have to make lenses
of all shapes and sizes.
Sometimes, the lenses they make
are much bigger than the average pupil.
The trick to getting them
on? As Eyeworks told Insider,
put your chin up and turn
your eyes to the left.
Working with bugs on
camera is no easy feat,
but, yes, you can train an insect to act.
Getting bugs to move
in the right direction
involves playing with light,
air, and room temperature.
Entomologist Steven Kutcher
can get all kinds of bugs
to perform on camera.
For "Spider-Man" and "Arachnophobia,"
he was hired to wrangle
the film's spiders.
For one shot in "Arachnophobia,"
a spider needed to crawl across the floor
and into a slipper.
So Kutcher devised a clever trick
using invisible vibrating wires.
By playing around with these,
Kutcher could get the spiders
directly where they needed to go.
When working on "Spider Man,"
Kutcher had to get a spider
to descend from a web
and then onto Tobey Maguire's hand,
where it could deliver the fateful bite.
Kutcher decided to stand above Maguire
while holding a paintbrush.
The spider crawled along the paintbrush
until it reached the end.
At that point, Kutcher tapped the brush,
and the spider dropped down.
He faced an even bigger challenge
in "Exorcist II: The Heretic."
He had to train 3,000 locusts,
which needed to cling onto
the screened wall of a cage.
However, most of these
locusts stood on the floor.
In order to drive them onto the walls,
he took a heat-emitting light
and shined it against the cage,
and the locusts subsequently
flocked towards it.
When a sex scene is filmed
for a movie or TV show,
it is crucial that the
actors feel protected
and not violated on set.
For this reason, the role
of intimacy coordinator,
which is relatively new to Hollywood,
has proven to be essential.
An intimacy coordinator, like Ita O'Brien,
is tasked with coaching
actors on sex and love scenes.
The most crucial part of her job
is making sure these
moments are done safely
and with clear consent during this time.
The motivations behind these
scenes are clearly established.
O'Brien worked with the cast
of the Netflix series "Sex Education."
She had to make sure the cast was safe
and prepared for the
show's intimate moments.
For these scenes, she created cushions
and flesh-colored articles of clothing.
These items gave the cast the
ability to cover themselves
as well as extra barrier of protection
during the simulated sex scenes.
Babies don't always cry on command,
so when you need one to wail on camera,
that's when you bring in a professional.
Elaine Hall is a baby wrangler,
but she also describes
herself as an interpreter.
Unlike with adult actors,
babies can only be on set
for a limited amount of time,
as they can only legally
work for four hours a day.
This means that Hall needs to get babies
to master their scenes in
as few takes as possible.
She has many tricks for how to do this.
If she needs to make a young
actor look happy in a scene,
she might attach a funny-looking
face to the camera lens.
But what about making a baby cry,
like she did for a scene
in "Akeelah and the Bee"?
[baby crying]
Well, she got really,
really involved and even
started sobbing herself.
[crying]
According to Hall,
when the baby heard her crying,
the baby immediately
started crying herself.
Then, to get the baby to stop,
Hall stopped crying and reassured the baby
that everything was OK.
Oh, and objects like a
rattle or a bell also help.
While actors are sometimes
given rubber swords,
especially for really dangerous stunts,
there are times when
they need real weapons
for utmost authenticity on camera.
Enter blacksmith Tony Swatton,
who's worked on over 200 movies.
Yes, he is a real blacksmith
who makes actual, functioning
swords for Hollywood.
Cameraman: Whoa!
Narrator: Swatton's weapons
look great in close-ups
and give the actors the feeling
of holding a real weapon,
which in turn makes their
performances even better.
His job isn't as easy
as just creating any
old weapon out of metal.
He needs to be really
accurate to match the setting.
For instance, when he worked
on "The Mask of Zorro,"
he created a curved hunting blade
that would have been used in the 1500s
for Antonio Banderas.
Besides being hyper-specific,
he also needs to make
multiple versions of a weapon
for different purposes.
For example, while he will make
a steel sword for close-ups,
swords made out of aluminum
are better for sequences involving action
and actual sword fights.
You can see here with the
steel blade Swatton made
for Johnny Depp in
"Pirates of the Caribbean."
Swatton has worked on some movies
that involved large battle sequences,
like "The Last Samurai."
For that, he wasn't just
making weapons for Tom Cruise;
he also had to make
about 600 aluminum blades
for all of the extras in
the biggest battle scenes.
Ian Phillips: Thanks for watching.
It takes a whole lot of talented people
to make your favorite movies.
What other movies would you
like to learn more about?
Let us know in the comments.